uh speaking of anti-vaxx we actually
have some
i think it's good news anyway uh
remember that wisconsin pharmacist
who very early on tampered with 500
doses of the vaccine
making them unusable he has now been
sentenced to three years in federal
prison this is good news the only
question is should he have gotten more
time in prison and i'll talk about that
in a moment
cbs 58 is reporting that stephen
brandenburg
the ex-pharmacist he is no longer a
pharmacist you will be glad to know
the ex-pharmacist convicted of
intentionally tampering
with more than 500 doses of the moderna
covet vaccine
was sentenced to three years in federal
prison on tuesday brandenburg was a
third shift pharmacist
at advocate aurora health hospital in
grafton
where he admits to intentionally
removing dozens of vials of the moderna
coronavirus vaccine
from refrigeration 57 doses were
administered to co-workers before
hospital officials
found out about this and destroyed the
rest of the doses
the 57 doses were determined to be still
effective
and did not produce health effects for
the patients who receive them
at his sentencing brandenburg told the
court he was greatly ashamed of his
actions
and he took responsibility for them his
defense attorney detailed how his life
spiraled prior to the incident he had a
messy divorce
he had mental and emotional issues he
had a sense of disillusionment with work
and with the stress of the pandemic uh
but his former employer
was very angry and insisted he needs to
be punished that this has impacted
hospital staff
who are now just trying to rebuild
confidence in the system there that this
won't happen again government
prosecutors asked for 51 months meaning
four years three months
the judge said that uh the guilty plea
the lack of criminal record and other
factors led to a
three-year sentence that the judge feels
is
just but not excessive in addition to
being imprisoned for three years the
judge ordered brandenburg
to serve three years of supervised
release and to pay about 83 000
in restitution to the hospital now this
is just the federal case
there's also a state case related to
this pending against brandenburg
we will see what happens there so first
and foremost three years is this enough
time
um yeah i mean i guess so what what i
think about is
um if indeed
so a bunch of these doses 57 of the of
the 500 tamper doses were given to
people
but then the rest of the 500 were thrown
out this was really early on in the
pandemic this was
when there was really limited vaccine
supply and they were really only going
to healthcare workers and those at the
absolute absolute highest risk
so delaying 450 doses 443 doses which
was what just
was thrown out due to the tampering
that realistically could have led to
some really high-risk people not getting
their dose
for a longer period of time and some of
them could have caught the virus and
some of them could have died now
it may have happened or it may not have
i don't actually know whether that
happened i don't know whether we can
even
say for sure but people
may have or could have died as a result
of this
and so three years i don't know what i
do know is
these people have to be made an example
out of now you can always come in and
say as as was argued this was a person
who was
um not doing well emotionally and
mentally and all of the stuff and
clearly those were mitigating factors in
terms of the the the sentencing
but a signal has to be sent that this is
just an absolute
no uh this is i mean would we say it's
equivalent to tampering with medication
is it equivalent to doing something to a
medication you're dispensing to someone
who
may be seriously ill and depending on a
medication to stay alive
would it be equivalent to messing with
the medication doing something with it
that makes it not work or uh dispensing
the wrong medication i mean it seems
that it would be at least at that level
and it was deliberate it was not an
accident
um i saw a funny comment online saying
just another victim of cancel culture uh
he spoke out
in some sense against the vaccine by
doing this and now he's been canceled
i hope that those are jokes the these
folks have to be made
examples out of and threw away his
career
no longer licensed licensed as a
pharmacist
not good times not good times for mr
brandenburg
but it has to be taken seriously my
question for you is
is three years the right sentence
prosecutor is asking for
four years three months the judge saying
three years do you feel it's too harsh
not harsh enough or just right let me
know
you can comment on this story on the
david pakman show facebook page which
you can find at facebook.com
davidpakmanshow and don't forget
the second david pakman show youtube
channel which with
exclusive clips from the backyard garden
as well as from the david pakman show
live streams you can find it at
davidpakman.com
pacmanlive second youtube channel
barreling to our first 5 000 subscribers
quick break and we will be right back
after this